hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
chapters 12 13 and 14 of alkun of york's
treatise on virtues and vices very
clearly reflect the christian framework
and perspective that he's working in
they are on confession
repentance and conversion to god so
these are are things that are central to
the christian life and to
you could say reformation of the
individual
human being they connect up with some of
the earlier chapters
and they figure into the work as a whole
you could say that without these from
alkaline's point of view
all the other stuff that you can do is
great
but it's not going to take hold and
really be
effective and one of the grand themes
that runs throughout all three of these
chapters
is that
human beings have a choice they can
engage in these things now
or
they're going to happen later but
they're going to happen later in the
life to come in a way that
won't lead to anything good
for the person but will be happening too
late for them so you know confession
you know the uncovering of one's flaws
one's vices one's sins one's evil deeds
it's gonna happen sooner or later the
question is do you want to be to some
degree in charge of when it happens
likewise repentance is going to happen
sooner or later do you want to do it now
or do you want to do it later and then
conversion is something that can't
really happen
later on but you can choose to do now
rather than at some future point within
this particular life so let's look at
confession first he tells us scripture
exhorts us frequently to free to the
medicine of confession and so this is a
common metaphor that gets used medicine
at the time now we disguise the taste of
medicine in many ways or when we give
somebody a shot we often give them a
painkiller first or something like that
something to numb the pain medicines
were not generally liked in ancient and
medieval times but they're good for you
and so
you take them because it's better for
you otherwise confession
is absolutely essential
because it allows sins
the bad things that we do to be
judged
because they've been brought out in the
open
and then to be forgiven as he says
so he says um
scripture exhorts us to this not because
god needs our confession it's not like
god has an interest in us confessing
because god just you know has a you know
he wants to know what's going on or
something like that he can see inside
everybody's hearts anyway he wants
people to be honest about what's going
on
so he says
we cannot be saved otherwise unless we
confess the sins we have we unjustly or
negligently have done the person who
accuses himself in his sins the devil
will not have him to accuse again in the
day of judgment so it's a way of like
cheating the devil that's actually kind
of a throwaway line though because what
is it really about he tells us it's a
great medication right it helps to
heal
the person and he says
he who hides his sins will not be set
straight but whoever has confessed and
relinquished them relinquished is the
key thing there will
follow mercy the great medication of
salvation this is a beautiful beautiful
line here
is
not to repeat the things we have done
wickedly
not to re-wound
the scars of earlier wounds so when we
do things wrong we're not just like you
know offending the neighbor offending
god we're screwing ourselves up we are
wounding our own
souls sometimes our bodies as well
and so
by
not doing the same stupid thing or
tempting thing again
we're not re-wounding
the scars of previous wounds
and this is an interesting metaphor you
can find this used in other places for
example epictetus the stoic philosopher
in talking about
anger and the need to like you know calm
your anger says don't you know lash
yourself on the scar of a previous
lashing right don't reopen up the
scars that are there and confession
allows this to happen
provided we don't do the same damn thing
over and over and over again
so he says you know now is the time for
us to actually do that is the time of
forgiveness to those repenting
if we wait around
we're going to repent later on but it's
not going to be particularly helpful so
he says
he who hides our sin hides his sins and
blushes to confess healthily now has god
as a witness and he will have him as a
revenger a person judges himself most
rightly in this time
lest he be judged by god to perpetual
damnation but he also says another thing
god desires our confession and here's
another interesting line
so that he has a just cause for
forgiving now forgiving
is an action
that seems to go against justice to a
certain degree if god is judging people
in justice then maybe he shouldn't
forgive them but
here we see that mercy and justice
can be tempered together god can have
a just cause
in god's own view right
for forgiving so there's a very
interesting dynamic here that is
connecting these two things justice and
mercy which often seem to be opposite to
each other and we're going to also see
that involved in repentance when we move
on to that one in chapter 13. so he says
you know there's a lot of scripture
quotes that say we should repent
um you know the savior himself john the
john the baptist um
uh in in scripture in in you know
ecclesiasticus or sirach right um the
prophet isaiah
and then he talks about saint peter
talking about the dog returning to its
vomit right so
repentance pointed tensia
involves
two different things
lamenting one sins that's really
important he's got this metaphor of
lamenting crying tears you know being
actually sad sorrowful for the things
that you did but then
not doing the same thing over and over
and over again and actually at one point
alkaline says that um
you know if you're doing the same thing
over and over again if you're actually
you know you're sad about it but you're
not changing your life that's not really
repentance he is not washed clean who
bewails what he has done but does not
desert it and after tears repeats what
he has wept about those who after tears
return to worst this is where saint
peter says the dog returns to its it's
vomit a phrase that you might have heard
outside of a scriptural
context right so another thing that he
says it's really really interesting
how do we tell whether somebody really
is repentant besides changing their
their life changing their behavior
we can measure it
but you don't measure it
according to time
right by years
but instead by sadness of spirit and he
uses uh saint peter as an example here
if you don't know the story uh when
christ has been betrayed and is being
you know tried and will be executed
saint peter who's supposed to be this
rock you know on which the community is
going to be established betrays christ
or denies christ
three times
and peter is very very upset about this
right so it says true repentance is not
rated by number of years but sadness of
spirit once blessed peter soon received
forgiveness from the lord since he wept
very sadly for the fault of these three
denials although repentance may be of
short time
if the interior of the heart is moved by
sadness it is not despised before the
just judge god who considers the secrets
of the heart god does not require length
of time as much as way
the state of sincerity what what's
actually going on within you
so you know true repentance could
actually be quite short for example the
space of a few hours right the other
thing that's really interesting here is
this dynamic of mercy and justice
is involved here as well
a little bit later he says
god is merciful by nature
and is prepared to save through mercy
those whom he will not come to save
through justice he wants all to be saved
and no one to perish right so god judges
some injustice and in those judgments
find some of them lacking and some of
them just and the just you know they go
on and they're good right what about the
rest of us poor slobs who if we're
judged in justice
we're screwed well you know that's where
the judging in mercy
comes in
and that's where repentance opens up the
door for this confession and repentance
are not from alcuin's perspective
something that we give to a mean god
who's demanding you better give me what
i want no it's instead
opening up the possibility
for the divine to
judge us in mercy and say well
you're sad i get it you screwed up i'm
gonna let you in anyway
so that's you know a very important uh
interplay between
mercy and justice and then the last
thing in chapter 14 not delaying
conversion to god right and there's two
different titles for this in the
manuscript one is about conversion to
god the other is about not delaying
conversion to god so that kind of tells
you where the emphasis lies now what is
conversion so this comes from the latin
conversion right
vertre
is uh to turn to twist so
you're looking over here one direction
and you turn
in another direction now your
perspective has changed or you can turn
from evil to doing good you can turn
away from god towards god right just as
you could to a person
and so you know one of the key things
here is the question
when should you do this
because you know you could wait until as
he says
tomorrow you could put it off you could
say like saint augustine did lord give
me chastity incontinence but but not yet
because i still want to keep screwing
around and you know indulging my sexual
appetite right and we can do this with
gluttony i'm going to begin my diet
tomorrow you know my exercise program
starts next week we could go on and on
i'm going to curb my bad temper that i
have i i know i lost my temper today but
tomorrow i'll fix that and
so you know alcuin is saying
a lot of people go down this line of
logic but it's not a very smart one and
he says
um here we go it's it's dissolute and
paralytic
thought to think about tomorrow's
conversion and neglect today's
why do you neglect to be converted and
do not fear that unexpected death may
snatch away the day of conversion for
you don't you know people die suddenly i
mean you could die tomorrow you could
actually die today or tonight so you
know why don't you
do this now he says
god promises to you who are converting
remission from sins he has not promised
to you security of living long so the
smart thing to do would be to convert
right away convert and
do penance so all of these things
conversion would involve doing penance
it would also involve repentance it
would also involve confession you see
how these are connected to each other
and he's got a line of reasoning here
for the people who
pay very close attention to the worldly
matters
but don't think about this issue of when
are you actually going to start living
a good life in a spiritual sense he says
why do you love a bad
life isn't that a stupid thing for you
to do
when a good life is available
and here's his line of reasoning he says
tomorrow you will say i will convert
why not today what evil you say if i
were to say tomorrow
what evil if today perhaps you will say
my life will be long i will say
it if it should be long let it be good
in short let it also be good who would
bear a long evil you don't want to have
a long bad meal
and you want to have a long bad life you
buy a house you want a good one you want
to take a wife you seek a good one you
want sons born to you you wish for good
ones and if i may talk about the
cheapest things
you buy shoes and you don't want bad
ones but you you are perfectly content
with a bad life how does that make sense
isn't that
imprudent isn't that foolish isn't that
bad for
you
and he goes on and he says um don't
delay you know why does your life offend
you which you wish alone to be bad so
that among your good things only you may
be bad the center of your life neither
should you delay to be converted to god
and don't defer from day to day you know
this is the smart way to do things so
all three of these are intimately
connected with each other and all three
of them are posing the reader
with a kind of decision
that they are being called upon to make
one of which with conversion has to do
with today or tomorrow the other two
have to do with are you going to do it
in this life or are you going to do it
in the next life where it's going to be
under circumstances that won't work out
quite so well
for you so uh very important chapters in
the heart of alchemins on virtues and
vices
you